hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome back
to abby's kitchen
as you can see the bump is gone so if
you missed it i had a baby boy
and i am back in the studio and it feels
so
so good it's a little chaotic here
trying to
balance a baby and work but to celebrate
my return
i thought i would do a review of a
heavily requested lifestyle youtuber
today
linda sun so linda has really hit the
ground running as her channel has grown
exponentially since she launched it
three months ago
so her videos focused largely on what in
a days or weeks
intuitive eating her exercise regime and
some clothing hauls i got a ton
of requests for this video which makes a
lot of sense to me since
i think we both speak to a lot of you
who may be drawn
in by wellness culture but also want to
avoid restrictive
and punishing regimes but before we get
into my nitty gritty
a few standard disclaimers here folks
the information
in this video is for entertainment and
educational purposes only
so you should always speak to a
healthcare provider about your
unique healthcare needs number two while
i do make an effort to include
relevant and well researched content in
my videos
please keep in mind that what you may
see may not fully reflect a creator's
diet
as we just can't necessarily review the
full catalog
of videos featured on their channel
number three
please be kind in the comments both here
and on linda's channel
for a trigger warning that some graphics
and discussions may potentially be
disturbing to some of my viewers so you
can always
feel free to skip this video if you'd
like and finally don't forget to
subscribe to this channel and ring that
little bell so that you
never miss out okay so let's kick things
off by chatting about linda's diet
and her what i eat in a days so linda's
channel has
only been around for a few months and
while i'm shooting this ahead and
therefore it may not be completely up to
date
i can tell you that at the time of
filming i literally watched
all of her content like every single
video
i can fully see why you all love her so
much
but when you watch a lot of linda you
quickly learn some of her
favorite meals and snacks so let's talk
about some of her
go-to's so breakfast
now breakfast for linda might be a
smoothie bowl
with some homemade granola peanut butter
and lots of fruit on top
a yogurt bowl with some greek yogurt
berries
and granola oatmeal made with chia seeds
nut butter maple syrup and fruit
or most frequently it's her famous
protein pancakes made with oat flour
protein powder banana almond milk
powdered peanut butter
and sometimes some chocolate chips and
then the whole thing is topped off with
some crunchy natural peanut butter
fruit and maple syrup so
let's talk about these breakfast options
all of which sound
insanely good and make me want a
breakfast do-over today
but in all of her morning meals she's
got a healthy dose of fiber-rich carbs
and antioxidants from the colorful fruit
and berries
she's also got more great fiber-rich
slow-digesting carbs in the form of
granola
oatmeal and the oat flour in the
pancakes
and like our girl stephanie from nutty
foodie fitness
she loves her pb so
i'm just so happy to see that she's not
afraid of loading up on the healthy fats
in the form of whole nuts in the granola
chia in the oatmeal
and peanut butter on well everything
i would probably say that the greek
yogurt bowl and the protein pancakes
are a bit more well balanced than the
other two options
since they offer the extra protein to
really help support her
obviously very active lifestyle if you
watch
her what i in a days or whatever weeks
you'll see that
she works out pretty much every single
day so
i think it's safe to say that she's got
some serious carb
and protein needs and since greek yogurt
offers about 20 grams of protein per cup
and her protein pancake recipe has about
40 grams of protein
when paired with all of the carb rich
toppings like the granola and the fruit
and maple syrup
i think they are both pretty amazing
post-workout meals
now let's talk about her lunch now in
one video
linda talks about how she often loves
having breakfast foods
for lunch because hello breakfast foods
are life
and like we already established she
loves her peanut butter so
sometimes you'll see her eat some of her
breakfast staples midday as well
but other times she often has some kind
of stir fry
or a meal built around her mom's famous
bing now you cannot watch a linda sun
video without seeing
a lot of bing so if you're not in the
loop
bing is kinda like a chinese flatbread
meat
pancake sometimes it's made plain or
sometimes it's stuffed with ground meat
or other ingredients it's obvious that
linda's mom is a
bing master and has made me definitely
want this particular dish
so badly that i searched on ubereats to
get it delivered to me
like this week but anyways i think my
breastfeeding hunger is definitely
showing
but often you'll see bing show up as
like a side dish at linda's meals
and other times it's more of like the
star of the show
so in one video she has her mom's famous
being
topped with avocado everything bagel
spice
parmesan cheese and a boiled egg aka
like the coolest
east meets west take on avocado toast i
have
ever seen and then in another video it's
like a classic avocado toast with eggs
and tomatoes which was actually a dish
that her fans suggested that she makes
now it turns out she liked it so much
she said she would be putting it more
regularly
into her meal rotation now both of these
avocado
loaded lunches are perfectly balanced in
my books
we've got carbs in the bread or the bing
we've got healthy fats and fiber in the
avocado
and some high quality protein in the egg
now if she wanted to beef up the veg
she could definitely serve this with
like a little side salad
but since she's already got like a lot
of produce and grains at her breakfast
i'm not particularly worried about her
fiber needs for the day
on other days linda opts for something
like a stir-fry type lunch
which i think is always a great example
of balance
so on one day it's an amazing looking
kimchi fried rice
where she's got protein in the eggs and
the shrimp
carbs from the rice fat from the cooking
oil and of course
lots of veggies on board she's even got
some added probiotics
in the kimchi and what i like most of
all about this
is that she doesn't talk about eating
the kimchi because it's anti-bloating
or whatever diet culture tells us it's
likely just the flavor that she really
likes
now as for dinner we're seeing a greater
reliance on
more traditional chinese fair likely
because
linda puts such a huge priority on
eating with her family
and her mom seems to do most of the
cooking in the house
and i love that she eats with her family
i mean there's tons of evidence to
support the emotional benefits of
regular family meals so research
suggests that eating together
as a family is often associated with
better academic performance
higher self-esteem greater sense of
resilience
as well as lower risk of substance abuse
teen pregnancy
depression eating disorders and obesity
when i coach parents on how to reduce
meal time drama
and picky eating with their young kids
my number one suggestion
is always family meals and i talked a
lot more about this
in my division responsibility video
right here
but in terms of these dinners i like
that we do see a mixture of
vegetarian and animal protein even linda
herself says she rarely eats beef
and relies more readily on things like
eggs seafood
tofu and some chicken but again balance
is inherently built into these family
style meals
so one night we've got protein from the
tofu carbs from the brown rice sweet
potato and
baozi i think that's how you say it
please correct me
healthy fats in the peanut sauce and
fiber rich
sauteed veg this looks crazy flavorful
and i would say it's flavorful because
linda isn't afraid of sauces
and fats which i feel like so many other
lifestyle youtubes are another night
we've got some carbs from the rice
protein from the eggs and fish and some
fat plus fiber from the eggplant sauteed
in oil
honestly her food may not always be
instagram worthy
but it's simple balanced and i bet it
tastes
really good her portions are also
totally normal for a girl her size
we're not seeing massive bowls of kale
or like three times her protein needs
like we see
so often here on youtube and while some
people might comment that she
seems to eat a lot of carbs i would say
that it's not at the expense of other
macronutrients and it's still within the
45 to 65
recommended range for macronutrient
distribution
and considering she is doing mainly
cardio heavy hit
training she probably really needs that
fuel
but without any food rules she's likely
just responding to her body's unique
needs okay let's round it out with some
snacks which
like her main meals definitely reveal
some themes
so some days she has just like straight
up fruit oftentimes it's kiwi or
melon and other times she pairs her
fruit with things like yogurt
and granola obviously you guys know i
would say that the latter will make a
more
satiating snack because we've got some
fat and some protein
in there with the carbs from the fruit
and the granola
but i also get that sometimes you just
want like a little some something to tie
you over
and a little bit of fruit is really good
for that now linda is
also obsessed with these crab snack
things
which i had to look up because clearly
they're worth writing home about
so these are actually broad beans but
they're crab row flavored so while they
are high in salt
they do have a good amount of protein on
board
one of those little packets would
actually make
a pretty awesome accompaniment to like a
piece of fruit
if she wanted to have like a more
complete and more balanced
satisfying snack the other linda
favorite as you probably know is
popcorners which is kind of the only
kind of deity
snack food that i really see her eat but
in terms of convenience foods
they are a totally fine choice if she
enjoys them
they've actually got like a little bit
of protein per ounce
and for a chip-like snack they're
actually also
relatively low in salt so she wanted to
up the satiety factor in these
since there really isn't any fiber in
corn based chips like these
she could dip them in some hummus for
protein
or some guacamole for some healthy fats
but i also just get that sometimes you
just like them as is
and finally let's talk dessert which can
be
really easily summarized by just one
main food category
ice cream i feel like i've been
introduced to so many new ben jerry's
flavors
just by watching linda's channel which i
love
because i too am ice cream obsessed
but whether she's cutting herself pieces
of ice cream cake
or tucking into that amazing netflix and
chill flavor of ice cream
she does so in a morally neutral
nonchalant way
that ice cream cake for example was
slowly consumed over
multiple days and multiple videos and
her ice cream portion
seemed totally aligned with a normal
healthy
appetite and relationship with food she
was neither binging on an entire tub in
a cheat day fashion
nor was she weighing out and perfectly
measuring
a specific half cup serving she's
able to clearly eat what satisfies her
and then kind of put the rest away
i acknowledge that this is just not very
possible for a lot of you
so if you're struggling with mindless
eating and you're still
on your food freedom journey i think
that putting some ice cream
into a bowl is a really good place to
start
then when you finish that portion check
in with yourself to see if you are maybe
not satisfied yet
and you want more if you do you can give
yourself that permission
unconditionally to go get more but at
least this gives you
some time to consider your hunger cues
and to check in with yourself
emotionally
and physically before you're just eating
on autopilot
okay so now that we have shared some of
linda's typical meals and snacks
what can i say about her general pattern
and relationship with food
well there's so much good to say about
what i'm seeing here
but i do want to start by discussing
linda's history
and let's watch a clip a huge part of
the guilt for me was needing to have
full control over all the meals that i
ate i need to eat perfect then i need to
exercise to burn off what i ate
counting every calorie and only eating
good foods
and if i wasn't in control oh my guilt
the shame the sadness
just attacked me and to be honest that
really just isn't living
okay so in linda's august video about
food guilt
she talks about how in the past she
really let the media perpetuate certain
beliefs that
some foods are good and others are bad
and that it resulted in her assigning
moral value to herself
she also talked about how she recently
realized
that the more that she would restrict a
food the more that she would end up
wanting it and this would end up in this
kind of vicious cycle
that basically took over her life i mean
has this girl been studying my intuitive
eating series because
the woman just nailed it and for a young
19 year old the girl has some tremendous
insight that i certainly did not have at
her age
i mean her mom should definitely be
really proud if you watch enough of her
channel you'll see a bunch of
inspirational quotes
peppered around linda's channel that
serve as great evidence
of how her relationship with food has
changed over the years
for one in her video on letting her
followers choose her diet
she talks about how food shouldn't be
your entire life
but that for her when she started to let
herself have the food that she craved
her body learned that it wasn't going to
be restricted anymore
and that she didn't have to obsess over
it she then goes on to say that if you
were to look back
at your life in 10 years time you
wouldn't remember the calories that you
ate
or the workout that you did at home
instead of going out with your friends
you would remember the experiences that
you had with people
that you love where food and exercise
weren't the only thing that you could
think about so if we look at my
intuitive eating series
this is a great example of principle
number three
make peace with food so if you need a
little bit of a refresher
definitely go watch that video and then
come back right here
then in her video on what she eats to
lose weight
she says i want to eat because it's fuel
i don't want to mindlessly eat because i
won't feel good later
i want to move my body because i deserve
to be healthy
now this is an advanced concept to grasp
for those starting out with intuitive
eating
but it is definitely the end goal that a
lot of us strive for
this eating and moving for pleasure and
for physical comfort
while also allowing for emotional
pleasure is
really what happens when all of the
intuitive eating principles
work together as one in another clip
she describes this as focusing on the
after feeling that is how do you feel
after eating a certain food do you feel
energized
sluggish do these things put you in a
good mood
etc so while we don't want food to play
into our subjective sense of self-worth
we do want to notice how foods make us
feel
both emotionally and physically in the
most
non-judgmental way possible remember
principle number four be the food
anthropologist
but i also love that her diet reflects
her laid back yet respectful approach to
food in her body
she eats the food she loves ice cream
pancakes
her mom's famous bing but her meals
incorporate a lot of nutritious
ingredients
like peanut butter yogurt fruit eggs and
veggies
also her portions are indicative of a
normal
balanced appetite and not one that's
bouncing between states of restriction
and binging and i love that she's also
more concerned with sitting down to a
family meal enjoying whatever her mom
puts on the table then controlling every
single micronutrient and macronutrient
that falls on her plate but now let's
move on to another
big question what kind of health and
wellness information
does linda share on her channel now
first i have to tell you that
when you guys first directed me to her
videos i was a little turned off by some
of the titles that i saw since
you were all telling me that she's all
about intuitive eating and body
positivity etc
yeah i was seeing a lot about weight
loss and cheat days
and flat stomach in her thumbnails i was
really worried that she was going to
turn
intuitive eating into another weight
loss diet
fad but when i actually watched her
videos
i did see that this was largely kind of
just click bait
it's like linda was saying gotcha now
that i got you here
listen up this is what you actually need
to know
in order to live really well now i do
know
that a lot of hayes proponents would
still interpret linda's content
as appropriation and misuse of the body
positivity movement
but i've done a lot of thinking on this
issue
over the past year and at this point in
my journey
i'm in a place where i would
respectfully disagree with that
sentiment
i stand with linda i would say that it's
important to acknowledge that intuitive
eating
in the full sense and intentional weight
loss
are not exactly compatible concepts at
least not how the original founders
conceptualized it
don't be mad at me for saying that i
mean i didn't write the book
evelyn tripoli and elise rush did and
the model really does suggest
that you have to actively reject the
diet mentality
in order to fully embrace intuitive
eating
but while linda's content is click-baity
i don't think she's explicitly promoting
intentional weight loss
anywhere the most she has said is that
her body has changed a certain way when
she stopped
overanalyzing everything that she put in
it i will also say that it is very
important that
those of us within privilege acknowledge
that our lived experience
is very different than those in larger
bodies and therefore
our experience of something like
intuitive eating and not dieting
may come with a lot less risk especially
in the public eye
this is why my content is just so
riddled with disclaimers
but in one of linda's videos i also saw
that she had
a disclaimer of her own stating that
just because
eating and working out a certain way
resulted in her losing weight
or her having a flatter stomach etc it
doesn't necessarily mean that the same
is going to happen to others
so yeah ultimately i do see a lot of
value in people
of all body types spreading the
intuitive eating and the body positive
messages
as long as they're not in the same
breath of promising
weight loss to everyone who tries the
method out
i'm gonna be working on a whole video
about this but anyways when i watched a
lot of her videos
i felt like they were more like
inspirational pep talks
than dogmatic lists of wellness rules
her way of communicating wellness
information is informed
yet gentle and kind so you don't walk
away feeling bad that you aren't eating
the way that she is
or that you're not able to think about
food the way that she does
in fact in one viral video where she
tests the workouts and diets of a bunch
of popular youtubers which is a pretty
cool video
she says that wedding in a day videos
should be for inspiration
not comparison and that just because you
might work out
or eat like a youtuber doesn't mean that
you're ever going to
look like them amen to that
so let's talk about some of the themes
that i see in her content
that i think that we can all learn
something from first
she doesn't equate weight with health in
her video on
what she eats to lose weight which turns
out like i said
is more click bait than anything
explicitly restrictive
she talks about how she's now actually
the heaviest that she's ever been but
she says that once she took the emphasis
and focus off of her
weight she was able to achieve true
health
happiness and strength she also said
that instead of focusing on what she
couldn't
directly control her weight she focused
instead on what she
could control that was her behaviors
and general lifestyle especially because
in her words
you can't hate your body into being
healthy
love it the result was that in breaking
up with her scale
she was able to fall in love with
exercise
family and food reiterating that weight
and health are not synonymous terms
second she promotes gentle nutrition
remember that last tenet of intuitive
eating
so linda offers some really great real
world examples of them so
let's just check it out really quick
also food wise i'm all for eating
everything my body craves but i also
know that i need to take care of my body
with nutrients and antioxidants
and beautiful fruits and vegetables not
because i want to lose weight but
because that's how i show my body that i
care for it
i love that linda understands the
delicate balance between choosing foods
that you just enjoy because
they're fun and that are also nutrient
dense so to linda
healthy foods are not low calorie diet
foods
they're foods that make her body and
mind feel
good and since we're on the topic of
intuitive eating principles
she's also rocking the concept of joyful
movement
let's take a look wrong speak up and be
yourself unapologetically
okay seriously does anyone else just
love watching the sun family work out
from her parents pretty impressive moves
to her brother's constant farts
to the banter between the whole gang
i want to see a reality show with these
people where
90 of it is just like push-ups planks
and pranks i mean she also says that
working out in the morning sets her mood
for the day
and i think that's a great revelation
and also
non-punishing motivation to exercise and
that takes me to
number four linda's emphasis on the
power of social connection
linda talks a lot about the importance
of her family in her life
not just for physical health like as
workout buddies
but for her spiritual and mental health
as well in one video she describes her
family as her light at the end of the
tunnel
which i thought was such an insightful
statement for such a young person to
make i think we all need to just focus
on that sentiment
ourselves in this crazy 2020.
but number five she redefines self-care
for gen
x now if you google self-care ideas
you're largely going to come up with
some home face masks and
like a list of the best mani pedis in
your city but linda explicitly calls
this out as being pretty superficial
instead she lists things like spending
time with your family
logging off social media smiling more
exercising
and eating what makes her feel satisfied
as some of her ways to practice
self-care
she also talks about the benefits of
just taking a break
and that success doesn't need to mean
working harder
faster stronger etc all the time nor
does it mean doing things to make others
happy or conforming to society's
expectations
again that seems like a really
mature concept for an almost 20 year old
to grasp
number six she respects her body
this is another great example of some of
the intuitive eating tenets in action
so in her video on how she loves her
body
she shares that when she stops seeing
her body through
like an aesthetic lens and instead
started to see her body as something
that carries her through life every
single day
she was really able to get on a path
towards self-love
and by shifting her value of herself
from her body
to other things like her intelligence
and kindness
and compassion she was able to build up
the confidence
to take better care of her body i just
want to say that there's nothing wrong
with having aesthetic
goals and not loving your body all the
time
doesn't make you an intuitive eating
failure
but respecting it by giving it kindness
through joyful movement and energizing
food
is the goal that we really want to
strive for so if you need a refresher on
respecting your body
check out my video right here all right
then finally
who would benefit from some of linda's
content
linda's content is literally a
motivational ted talk
set to some really fun food vlogs and
food porn
i can see why people are obsessed i am
obsessed
so linda is the voice that we all need
in our head
she's the youtuber that we all need in
our feeds
this girl is 19 years old and wise
beyond her years of course linda is not
a nutrition professional but
she also doesn't claim to be nor is she
doling out nutrition information or diet
tips or
prescriptive food rules she just seems
like a girl on her own body liberation
journey
sharing her own learnings with the world
and i like that she isn't dogmatic about
what's worked for her in one video on
what she did to lose weight
she specifically says do what works for
you
she says if you want to do intermittent
fasting or keto
or weigh yourself every day great find
your own journey
and own it for yourself yes
some body positivity advocates would
argue that her content
particularly around weight loss or
having a flat tummy etc
is anti-body positivity largely because
it's often seen as deceptive
to discuss intuitive eating in any
context of changing your body
and like i said yes as it was written by
the founders intuitive eating
and weight loss are not compatible
concepts
but i also don't think that linda is
actually promoting weight loss or
promising weight loss from intuitive
eating
even if her choice of words might be a
little bit unclear at times
if i'm being honest i sometimes do think
that there's a lot of policing of words
in the haze
and the body positive space and i myself
have been guilty of it
in the past since i was just kind of so
engrossed in trying to quickly navigate
and learn about that world but from
where i am now
i'm not always sure how productive it is
to
nitpick on people's journeys so as long
as linda isn't explicitly promising
intuitive eating as a means to an
end goal of weight loss i think it's
totally fine to share her unique
experience but intuitive eating is not a
weight loss diet
i repeat it is not designed at its core
to result in weight loss but depending
on where you're starting and how the
tenants improve your relationship with
food
it absolutely can result in weight loss
when you're more in tune with your
hunger and your fullness cues and have
learned how to respect your body you may
find yourself
less interested in overeating previously
demonized foods
you may find that you want to move your
body in ways that feel
good and not punishing and you may just
find some more sustainable ways to eat
that actually
feel good and i think throughout all of
the content that i've watched from linda
she describes this really well but of
course
if you find it triggering to see or hear
any talk of body transformations
or weight loss then this may not be the
channel for you
otherwise if you're on a journey
yourself where you're looking to
challenge your food fears
learn what gentle nutrition looks like
in real life with or without the goal of
weight loss
i think linda's channel is a great
resource to have
so folks that is all for today if you
like this video
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below with any other
youtubers channels that you want to see
me review
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you